most people say that living in Los
Angeles requires you to own a car in
order to survive today I challenge that
assumption with the rise in electric
motor and battery tech utilizing
alternative electric Transpo like
electric bicycles is more viable and it
has ever been before but have we gotten
to the point of being able to ditch our
cars altogether let's find out for the
next week I will remove all automotive
transportation from my life and replace
it with only an electric bike
[Music]
gangster-style I only live about eight
miles from the studio which means that
using an electric bicycle for that is
totally possible also I got to make up
for some of the gas goes in this truck
does Nick good to meet you the most
common thing people you know you're
gonna think about what you're saving on
is gas right yeah you got like a wear
and tear in the vehicles you're not
doing as many oil changes tire change
all that stuff the miles are so low now
that his insurance is almost cut in half
because he's out of setting hundred
miles a year so considered a luxury
vehicle yeah once you get the exercise
he said the biggest thing got though
from commuting was his that time
changing the Samaniego name is a big
deal Sam and I have called it the salmon
eco channel very since it was just me
and him we're changing the name from
salmon eco to corridor crew we can't
half-ass it we need to do it right it's
not just a name change it's a full-on
branding change if somebody hasn't come
to the channel in a little while they
see that it says corridor crew they need
to know that it's the same channel and
it's the same people we need to enhance
it for art both Sam and I have been
pretty strict saying we need to have
everything set to go at the same time a
little intro to the video the channel
name change the icon change and most
importantly the banner the banner needs
to be good it needs to be photos of the
crew it needs to speak to the team that
we are so Sam has told me he's going to
dedicate his patch
his artistry to getting a really solid
banner photograph for us sounds like he
has a pretty cool vision for it and I'm
looking forward to it so I'll wait for
him to call me in for a picture why is
picture day so stressful I'm taking
pictures but I don't really have a
direction so I'm just gonna wing it see
that big one yes take a baby step
backwards baby support like what will I
into thanks that's such a great photo
that's that's profile photo worthy right
next lighting setup I chose the first
light that was plugged in it's an LED
blanket we played around with those last
year you get this nice soft diffusion
here you'll realize they're a gangster
style
yeah the bike I'll be using is the blix
Comfort Prima from the Blitz electric
bike company it comes equipped with the
Shimano steps mid Drive electric motor
which is an assisted power system that
lets you bike as you pedal there is no
throttle and no special knowledge
required all you do is get on the bike
and the steps Motor Assist along the
aluminum alloy frame is built
specifically for this motor and when
combined with the 700 centimeter
double-wall alloy wheels and padded
leather saddle and leather grips it
delivers a comfortable smooth ride it's
a commuter bike and commuting is exactly
what I'll be doing
it's 13 miles miles ok 13 miles so
you're gonna be getting here this could
pick you like yeah 35 40 minutes I mean
that's a lot of minutes I mean I would
be interested to see it as possible
because from my experience in LA like
there's not even sidewalks and everyone
here drives like a maniac so it's like
literally the whole world is fighting
against you yeah kinda I am now
officially on my first electric bike
commute I wanna be mostly taking two
rivers meaning I'm gonna go
an extra mile in a direction that I
don't want to go however there is a
shortcut if I take a set of abandoned
train tracks
I'll save about a mile on my trip do not
take the train tracks these are active
train tracks all right
and currently I'm stuck somewhere over
the 710 freeway this is the river path
the thing I really like about this
assisted power system is that you can
still get a workout in given the time it
takes to work out at home drive to the
studio and the time it takes to drive
back at night I actually think I saved
myself a half hour a day la it's one of
the most sprawled out cities in the
entire United States
honestly like I love biking I love
biking my whole life and it's great and
then once I moved to LA I stopped it the
city was just fighting me it's kind of
scary to buy cute cars could this go
horribly wrong yes if it does then we
all know that la is the most non
pedestrian friendly city on the history
of the planet which it probably is
[Music]
an area that's not set up the bicycle
transportation whatsoever
definitely 45 minutes Hey look there's
rent day three commute at home and
there's two things I've noticed so far
number one that you get a lot of time
for thought and reflection when you are
out here effectively alone after a day's
work you get a lot of time to think
about it and on your way in you get a
lot of time to think about your way in
and what you're gonna do that day so
that's really really nice I really
really like that
number two however know your gear know
what you might need along the way and
the only way you really get to know your
gear is by using the gear that you have
I've already had to cancel an
appointment I've been trying to go to
the eye doctor for about a month now and
today I finally had an opportunity to go
but there's no possible way that I could
take my bike to the eye doctor and get
over to downtown LA for another meeting
that we have in time if I had a car
probably would have been able to make
both of those things but it's just too
far and not enough time this isn't a fun
day because I'm carrying a lot of weight
in this backpack right here I'm carrying
airsoft rifles they're heavy
they have batteries they have magazines
with bb's in them I got to take these
all the way to work I don't have a car
it's only one way to do that grind it
out between
filming and the traffic today is taking
me oh it's gonna take me over an hour
look at this so every time I have to
cross the road I need to wait a super
long time for traffic because you have
to roll with traffic across
intersections
this is to do this every day and replace
it with your car is not not not
enjoyable so I know we've been planning
to change the branding and I know the
name for the new corridor crew but
honestly Sam's been tucked away in the
cave during this whole process I had no
idea what the new assets look like at
all is it official
is it flipped we're turning the channel
name right now how you doing it Jake
like how to do it right now question are
we gonna have crew shirts now we get the
fancy dese let's Jake it's the merch
store back up send them the new designs
man black object you guys just wait chip
trust me the weight on the merch store
is gonna be worth it I promise you time
to announce our 1 million subscribers
street meat barbecue maybe not call it
street meat barbecue those street meat
barbecue dude it's a meet up barbecue in
a park in LA when we hit 1 million subs
so here's that sub button
that's what Jake forgot to end a
sentence with well announce it probably
announced it not here say that subscribe
button if you want to get us to this
part of India you mean that like our
viewers are part of the crew yes
so hit that subscribe button if you want
to be part of the corridor crew thank
you thanks red
putting over 200 miles in on this
electric bike I've come to the
conclusion that you can actually live in
this city without owning a car but that
said you're not going to be able to get
away with not using cars at all you're
still gonna need to rent cars do things
like rideshares
from time to time just to get around
this city why it's 500 square miles and
it's been built pretty much from the
ground up for cars but if you can find
the efficiency in your life to get by on
an electric bike you can actually do it
and you're gonna save a ton of money
that way too for me however I'm not
ready to give up cars just yet
huge thanks to the Blix bicycle company
for hooking us up with the electric bike
if you guys are interested in trying
this on your own go to blix bike comm
and use the offer code corridor 100 to
get $100 off your first bike you're
welcome
[Music]